hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the seven foods you must never
ever eat okay number one orange juice
now this might shock you but here's what
happens they pasteurize orange juice
which is they cook it they destroy
anything in it and you don't get a lot
of vitamin C it's just sugar water and
you're just going to spike the blood
sugars and it's going to come down
there's not a lot of nutrition after
they cook it because heating killed all
the enzymes and all the nutrition not
all of it but a lot of it okay so it's
kind of like drinking sugar water number
two soy protein isolates make sure you
read the ingredients on things because a
lot of them weight loss food and food
like protein shakes I won't mention any
names but a lot of vegetarian patties
are made with these soy protein isolates
this is really not a natural food for a
human it's it's not fermented it doesn't
do well in our bodies and it actually
irritates the liver so I would avoid
that high fructose corn syrup that's a
given and that's in a lot of sodas and
drinks and it's another even like salad
dressing they put it in there so it's
like a it's like a filler now number
four commercial meats with nitrates so
when you buy like bacon or sausage
roommates make sure it's nitrate free
because you don't you don't know what
you're getting these are there's studies
that show that it's linked to cancer so
you don't want to go down that road you
want to do grass-fed paleo hormone free
number five commercial milk so if you're
gonna do milk make sure it's organic or
hormone free at least because there's a
little hormone called our BST which has
some negative effects on the body so I
would avoid this and then also number
six TV dinners now I used to live on pot
pies and TV dinners and a very low
quality food because you actually have
you have the the protein the starch and
dessert all at one when you combine the
protein with the starch with the sugar
you are going to massively spike the
insulin same thing with the pot pies
where you have the crust and the meat
chunks and all the different star
Chinn there with the with the I guess
you have the gravy in there not good
okay last one is fruit that comes from
third-world countries so when you buy
Ares our fruit and it says it's from
Mexico or Chile different countries
there's a chance that they might use DDT
because in America it's illegal to spray
with DDT was banned I think in 1972 but
we're allowed to sell it to third world
countries so what's happening we're
bringing it back and we're getting
consumed and there's studies that show
that even children are being exposed to
UT well it's coming from this right here
I'll put a link down below all right so
all right put your comments below thanks
for watching
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video